there's chandler jones
back in march asking jj watt
what do you want to eat offering to be
his personal chef uh j.j watt going
hungry
in mini camp because chandler jones is
not there we're going to go through the
contract disputes that have caused guys
to miss mandatory mini camps good bad
and ugly as it relates to the
expected resolution let's start with
jones he's in the last year of a
five-year 82 and a half million dollar
contract turned 31 in february
he only played in one game last season
but he still has
61 sacks in five years since joining
arizona that's second in the nfl think
about that he played in one game last
year
and is still second over the last five
years in sacks in the nfl second only to
aaron donald at 65 and a half
how do you see this one ending what do
you do if you're the cardinals what do
you do if you're jones because this year
last year and this year began this
process of it's very difficult to hold
out into training camp
50 000 a day and it's non-waivable
yeah it works out to two million if you
stay away for all the camps so
how do you see this one playing out for
chandler jones due to make i think 15
million this year
yeah uh i i'm gonna say
bad like i'm gonna say bad good bad ugly
like good
some way somehow some deal gets figured
out something that way right
i don't know i mean maybe they could
find a way to sweeten it for one year
to maybe put it off a lot like what the
patriots did with stefan gilmore a
little bit just to do something like
that to make him happy
but ultimately i i don't know i mean
it's still it's a guy that missed a full
year you know except for in one game
hang on yeah
he missed he he had one sack oh one sack
in the five games sorry he'd
acknowledged to me
no but that doesn't matter we know he
was it's a word that i can't repeat
but either way he used one of your words
yeah yeah yeah well that's good
it's a proper time to use one of those
words so definitely
didn't play a lot a lot last year that's
the point
getting up there in years and doing
things like that
to where i just have a hard time looking
at it like
they're just gonna automatically extend
him right now with where they are in
their current place so i'm gonna say he
comes back with no deal
and they try to work something out maybe
during the year or something like that
but i don't see it happening
yeah look i what do you think i mean
it's a tough one
here's the problem if you're the
cardinals right you can get some real
cap relief
exactly if you get the guys signed yeah
the problem is
top of the market thanks a lot chargers
paying joey boasts a 27 million a year
like this is why danielle hunter was
unhappy in minnesota once boasted gets
27 million a year that changes
everything
but the problem is shaq barrett hits the
open market this year
stays with the bucks at 17. that's a big
gap
yes that's a 10 million dollar gap where
do you land
and chandler jones is 31. i i i think
that it makes sense
to come up with something closer to 17
than 27
the question is is it enough to make
chandler jones happy and i think at age
31 given the money he's made
yeah it might just have to realize
because because look what are they gonna
do they can trade him and is someone
else gonna pay him
what he's looking for i don't think so i
think this one will
end in an acceptable fashion
i know that's where i was going to be
happy right right he's still not going
to be happy
um but he's going to he they're going to
work it out
and uh that's what i think they'll work
it out and he'll stay there
he's still not gonna think he got as
much as he should so yeah like it's a
combination of good and bad is what
you're saying like it's not gonna be
what he wants but he gets a little
sweetener and something that way i know
he to me is one of the tougher ones
we're going to talk about here certainly
also because if he was determined let me
say this if he was determined
to not play for the cardinals he
wouldn't have sent that message to j.j
watt in march
that's a good point he would you're
right it would have shut down
yeah i i hear you you know and the other
thing too is
listen he's a good player there's no
doubt he's probably one of the more
underrated defensive players we've had
in football the last four or five years
but that age injured and then the
cardinals
you know they can get after the
quarterback they're kind of a blitzing
type team
they were one of the top sack teams in
football to where they could probably
look at it justify and go hey listen
we still got after the quarterback last
year you know even without you
and you're only your one sack and
everything like that so you know as more
we talk about i think you're right it's
going to be just a little bit of a
sweetener just to soothe it over for the
year
xavien howard the dolphins corner i
remember this was june of 2019 he had a
year left on his rookie deal
he signed a five-year extension putting
him under contract for six years
and the way they did the numbers on the
five-year extension
when you focus on new money average not
total value at signing but new money
average it put him
just a hair north of josh norman who at
the time was the highest paid coroner
at 15 million a year howard was at 15.05
million in new money the problem is
when you threw in the existing year when
you look at the full contract
it's less than 13 million a year he's
not much far ahead
of where he would have been if he had
played out his rookie deal and been
franchise tagged last year
he i think has realized also he's got a
new agent and the new agent doesn't get
paid
until there's a new deal done that's a
factor but i think howard has realized
that you know the the there there were
some liberties taken with the
structuring of the deal so he could feel
like the highest paid corner
in league history the reality is he's
not
and now he's trying to get there
especially having 10 interceptions last
year
and being regarded as a potential
finalist for defensive player of the
year no
i mean this this to me is one of the
more unique situations
i can remember with contract disputes in
a while for me i mean xavier howard
is one of the five best corners in
football yeah he's making less money
than the corner
opposite him who's not as good as him
and byron jones
so and of course yes he's seen the
jaylen ramsey contract and some of the
other things too
that of course is going to make him
antsy off of that but
still you know and mike you know me and
you we're we're pro
player we're pro player but this one's
hard for me to totally back the player
two years into the deal i know it wasn't
perfect
but like the first year of the deal you
only played four games
you know so there was four games you got
you know that money that year
okay great now it's year two you did
great there's no doubt
but i guess it's a little harder for me
to support the guy
where it's like okay you've only played
two-thirds of the
earth you know two-thirds of the game or
three-quarters of the games here
but he's outperformed but but i know
i know it's where it's a tough one for
me and i'm always usually pro player
player player player
but here's one where i just go i guess i
have a little more sympathy for the
franchise than normal in this one
here's the reality yeah he took the deal
and got
a significant amount of security and
certainty in 2019 when he was looking at
making
less than two million dollars right and
now
he doesn't like the deal that he took
two years later yeah because it's been a
good deal for the dolphins right
that's the challenge and and the reason
that i hesitate with this
is it's so much easier for the team to
rip up a deal
they don't like and move on than it is
for the player i know
to rip up a deal he doesn't like and
move on and until there's true
equality in that category i'm i'm i'm
always going to
take the position if you want more as
the player
go try to get it now the problem is you
don't have a lot of leverage
but at least try to get it and i think
he'll be there at training camp
and maybe they'll tell him one more good
year and we'll take kerry after this
season maybe that's what he's trying to
do maybe that's
where he's trying to get to that they'll
commit to after 2021
giving him a new contract and uh if they
make that momentum he shows up
and uh you know it's a good resolution
for everyone i think so that would be
the one that seems to make the most
sense because you're right i mean they
listen they did do them a solid either
way by doing the contract to doing those
type of things yeah was it a good deal
uh you're you're right now some of
that's got to go
on xavier howard there a little bit too
but yeah they did themselves a solid
they
bought low they bought low exactly right
and yeah that's that's sometimes
the problem as a player is you get that
money dangled out there in front of you
and you want to do it but now you
outperform it
and you want more i think he could he
stand on more solid ground
you know the team itself is finally
arrived
and now here he is kind of making it
about him i think everybody could
swallow a little bit better if he did it
after this year
two more real quick we don't have time
to delve into them we've talked about
them this week jamal adams i think he's
getting a contract before traffic camp
when they traded for him last year
that's part of the price that they knew
they were going to have to pay right
staffon gilmore
i don't know what's going to happen here
and i won't be surprised if he gets
traded
i don't know either i'm with you with
jamal adams it's only a matter of time
before he's the highest paid safety in
football that has to happen gilmore
man i don't know you're right i could
see a trade going down here
uh with the patriots and them just going
we got a great secondary we got jc
jackson we're gonna have to pay him
and let's move on and go from there i
wouldn't be shocked either mike i think
that's probably where i lean right now
too
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports